this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money
i'm your host george campbell and we are
taking your calls today about whatever
you want to talk about whatever's going
on in your life in your mind maybe
you're worried about inflation maybe
you've got a pile of debt you want to
clean up maybe you're investing for the
future and you're not sure how to move
forward i am here for you and i'm flying
solo today no co-host so we're we're
gonna either watch the world burn or
we're gonna have a fun show today and
i'm i'm hoping hoping for the latter
kelly is has her hands up high she's
encouraging me which is rare if you know
kelly in the booth so
give us a call if you're one of those
millennials or you're gen z and you're
going hold on give us a call how do i do
that does snapchat have that feature is
that a tick tock no you have to actually
there's a there's an app on your phone
that says phone and if you tap on that
you can dial this number
write it down folks triple eight eight
two five five two two five
jenna will pick up and if you're nice to
her she'll let you through and we will
talk about money
now the boomers out there you know how
this works you've been using this thing
for for centuries so if you're my mom or
dad you want to call in with some
encouragement if you're dave wherever
dave is who knows he's probably on a
beach somewhere sipping on a fancy drink
with an umbrella if he's listening in
dave can call in too it's a free show
and that's how we like it so give us a
call triple 825-5225
jay starts off this hour in phoenix
arizona jay welcome to the ramsey show
hey thanks for having me sure how can i
help
um so i just wanted to know if we should
still be making um minimum payments to
our
navient loans if we think
the settlement might um
purchase those loans potentially
well that's a great question first of
all jay uh speak directly into your
phone for me just so we can hear you
nice and clear
so what are the what are the terms of
the settlement that you've heard so far
um
so the reason why i think it might apply
to us is the school that my wife went to
the art institute in minnesota they have
since closed i mean they were part of a
uh
justice department class action suit for
predatory
um retreating practices and then um
obviously before when mine would be
about the
naviance uh creditory you know loan
what have you so yeah uh we're hopeful
that that will you know
that will fall in line with that but you
know
it's still saying that we have minimum
payments due
and my concern is some of the
stipulations that i i read into said
that um
some of the loans that would be forgiven
would be the ones that have uh
that haven't been paid in the last like
seven months or something like that so
i'm like
make sure you're making payments on
these or
well what happens if you don't make the
payment
i don't know
i don't like that i don't like that
option i mean if i'm in your shoes i'm
getting a lot of clarity about who this
is for if i'm going to get approved but
i'm not going to sit around for a year
not make payments or make minimum
payments i want this thing out of your
life whether or not the settlement
happens and whether it applies to your
situation so yes i would continue making
minimum payments until you get more
information but in the meantime i mean
you should know the results of this
pretty soon right
it says i will be notified by july
oh that is a long time
yeah here's my thing we do have other we
do have other debt that we're going to
pay down in the meantime it's just going
to rearrange our snowball a little bit
so like we could pay the caller that's a
lot of federal student loans that that
we can be paying what's the total amount
of your student loans
uh it has
sixteen thousand of which naviance
and
twenty five thousand is worth to say
okay so the only ones that could be
forgiven are those naviant ones right
yeah from that settlement and where does
that fall in your debt snowball
currently
uh it's our top two
okay number three is our
is our car
uh we owe about a little over 11 on that
so we were thinking of just throwing
everything at the car i suppose until we
figure out
see what shakes out in the next six
months
yeah so the car is your smallest deck
currently
uh no our um we have two
private navient loans um one is five one
is ten the car is eleven
well i mean if you wanna go ahead and
attack the car that's fine what i don't
want is for this debt just to sit around
and we don't have a resolution and they
kick the can down the road and now it's
august october and you waited all this
time and they said no we're not going to
forgive the loans
and right if i'm you i just want to take
control i want to be done it's not a
major amount of debt if this was a
hundred thousand dollars that could be
forgiven i might say all right well
let's let's wait and see how this shakes
down
but um
with your snowball and you guys
attacking this thing it's only gonna be
a few extra months right how much uh
what's your income household
uh we just got it up to about 150. heck
yeah
so with 150 how quickly you're going to
pay off all your debt total
uh
we could probably do it by the end of
this year but there
my wife is uh in a wedding party in
hawaii so that might you know
that potentially is like another like
three months maybe attacked on to the
end whoa how expensive is this uh
situation gonna be for her
uh
probably
uh we kind of budgeted it was like 3 500
ish so we're putting a couple hundred
bucks aside
okay well making 150 you guys should be
able to cash flow this and honestly you
could clean up the navient debt really
quickly and not have to wait and hope
for a settlement so that's what i would
do personally if i was in your shoes
if you want to start paying off the car
first
i mean that's fine but again i just
don't want this thing getting kicked
down the road and then you end up in the
same situation you were back at square
one
right but get the details i mean i would
get some real clarity if yes 100 chance
this is going to be part of the
settlement and it will be paid in july
and my loans are a part of that get some
clarity on that because i do think it
could help the debt snowball and that's
what your question is is you know could
this help our situation if we just wait
and let this be forgiven
but right i just i have very little
faith in the forgiveness system and i
understand this is a settlement this was
predatory
and i hope that happens more because the
as you know there's so many scam
situations out there where colleges are
you know price gouging and hurting the
students out there and saddling them
with student loan debt and you guys
happen to be a victim of that so if i'm
you i just want to take control and i
don't want to put my future in someone
else's hands or even in a settlement's
hands and hope for that situation
right yeah but thanks for the call jay i
hope it works out for you guys i do hope
that you get this thing figured out this
is beyond just a general student loan
forgiveness thing this is predatory
colleges
this is scam colleges that promised one
thing and became another and they're
shutting down and a lot of people aren't
a lurch and you're you're one of those
people unfortunately you and your wife
but it's a great question and i just
always choose to be in the boat of
taking control
and making a hundred fifty thousand
dollars
i mean this is a blip in your life
paying off 16k whether it's forgiven or
not
so i just don't want you to be stuck in
paralysis mode going well should we i
guess we shouldn't make these payments i
guess we should move on to the other
debt follow the plan the plan works
every time you work it use the debt
snowball list your debts from smallest
to largest regardless of the interest
rate and start to attack it and feel the
progress and feel the freedom as you
free up payment after payment
give us a call triple 825-5225
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast
all of which you can find on the ramsay
network along with the ramsay show
open phones this hour the number to call
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five you call us up we'll talk about
your life and your money james joins us
in st louis james welcome to the ramsay
show
hi hey how are you
doing well thank you how can i help
today
yes i have a question
regarding uh medical bill debt um my
wife and i have recently incurred about
ten thousand dollars
in medical bills that were due to a
unplanned emergency operation for her
delivering our baby and my question is
what is the best way for us to go about
paying that off without going into debt
to pay it off so you've got a ten
thousand dollar bill from the hospital
correct is this uh is have you contacted
them to let them know that you can't pay
this in full
well we are in the process of contacting
them trying to get that reduced
uh currently
the
the first option we were given is to pay
paid off 500 a month and we don't have
that kind of money currently to pay 500
a month on medical bills okay so that's
what they were willing to do is put you
on a payment plan of 500 a month
yes we are but we are going to contact
them again to try to get the bill
reduced further down than 10 000.
okay
and with this 10 000 how recent was it
uh
november the 18th is when the baby was
born
okay well you may have a hard time
trying to negotiate this bill down
because of how recent it is if it was
really old or if it was in collections
you may have an easier time trying to
negotiate it so it sounds like at this
point you need to negotiate down the
payment plan and attack this thing with
a vengeance do you guys have any other
debt
uh yes very very little um we have about
75 dollars in credit card debt and then
we have
one car that we're currently leasing but
i can't get out of it currently
okay you said 75 dollars in credit card
debt
correct okay so we can we can get rid of
that thing this month
oh yeah no problem at all what's your
household income
2500 a month
i'm the only income earner currently
and is that take-home pay or is that
gross
take home pay okay so we're bringing in
about 30 grand and you said your wife
isn't working she's with the baby at
home
correct okay what do you do for a living
i work in a warehouse a warehouse
are there any opportunities to
put in overtime at the warehouse
not anymore okay that went away does it
cut out yes
well
it sounds like you're about to pick up
some side jobs
are you open to that
um yes if i can get a side job a side
job or a different full-time job that
has better hours than my current
schedule currently i work 12 hour days
12-hour days and you're taking home 2500
a month
yes
i mean it's you may need a career change
i mean you could go deliver pizzas and
make more than that right now
if i'm you i'm going to be on the hunt
for a different job i mean do you love
your job
uh it has its pros and cons but i don't
see myself there for forever as a career
yeah
well on the career side uh we don't need
to get into that today but i want to
hook you up with ken coleman's get clear
assessment so i'll have jenna pick up
after we're done here and she'll get you
plugged in with that assessment that'll
walk you through exactly
what you were created to do how you're
wired what you will love doing and the
truth is you're going to make good money
doing it once you figure that out
because right now you have an income
problem
this debt is not insurmountable
total i mean obviously there are some
decisions made we're going we're going
to cut up the credit card we're going to
get out of this car lease when we can
and we're never going to look back and
never do debt again
right that's our plan
so if that's the plan going forward this
is a temporary situation where we need
to get your income up so that you can
afford the monthly payments afford to
put food on the table and support your
family
because that's really hard to do
at 2500 a month when you have a pile of
debt
this is going to look like a lot of long
nights for for you and that's why i'm
going man if you can work a job where
you're working 40 hours a week instead
of 12-hour days
and make more money and have time to do
a side job to bring in even more money
that changes this whole situation
okay so i would be looking around the st
louis area and seeing who's hiring what
are they paying what skill set do i have
that i can bring to the table
and what can i contribute in order to
clean up this mess
um and you can continue to try to push
on the negotiation but at the end of the
day
you're ten thousand dollars in debt and
we gotta clean up the ten thousand
dollars
um the credit card's gonna come first
and you said the only other kind of debt
is your car
lease correct i got 13 payments left on
that okay i would look out look into the
the buyout amount for that and see if
it's worth doing that to get out of this
lease because that is men i mean we call
it a fleece for a reason you just get
screwed on those car leases
and making
thirty thousand dollars a year
i don't know what kind of car this is
but i bet it's it's worth a pretty penny
right
uh
the sticker price on it when i got it
was 26 thousand dollars
man that is a large percentage of your
world
so it sounds like we're gonna get to
work and i know that that may not be fun
but right now you got to take care of
your family you got to take care of this
debt and then you're going to look back
and say never again never again am i
going to have to work 16 hour days
worrying about this pile of debt
worrying about my baby and my wife at
home
and that's going to change everything
for you
are you willing to do that
definitely okay i'm rooting for you man
i know i know you sound deflated like
more work i'm doing 12 hour days man i
had to take a break just to call into
the show but i'm telling you dude you're
going to look back at this and you're
going to say it was so worth it it was
so worth it to change my family tree
thanks for the call stephanie joins us
in ann arbor michigan stephanie welcome
to the ramsay show
hi how are you today doing great how can
i help
thank you i have a question about caring
for my father ongoing
he has to mention he just went into
memory care
he has some cash that would probably
last for about a year
however he also has a house
and two acres that's probably worth
about 150 000
that has a ladybird deed on it and if he
passes away the ladybird keeps it out of
proven it will go to myself and my
siblings
um
and it's my understanding that that
would shield it from medicare because
i'm medicaid i mean because i think
he's going to run out of money if he
lasts longer than a year
and
he would either have to pursue the
medicaid or sell the house and i just
was curious about your opinion on that
um
well what what is the house doing
currently just sitting there
uh well he just went in a couple weeks
ago so my sister's living there until we
can get it either ready for rental or
sale
and now that your sister is involved
here have you guys had an honest
conversation about what you guys want to
do like are you on the street yes we're
all we're all just kind of
trying to figure out
what will happen with it i think we
could all go either way we all get along
very well
and we can come to a consensus pretty
easily so yeah well if no one's gonna
live there as their primary residence
and it's just sitting there and no one
really wants to hassle with it i would
sell it
personally okay i mean if it doesn't
have like this big sentimental value and
we have big plans for this um i would
you said it would how much would it sell
for
uh probably somewhere around 150 000 or
just a little bit more and it's paid for
it is paid for
uh debt-free the the
it is my dad's only other asset since we
sold some other property
um and it's just the question of if i
believe it cannot be claimed by medicaid
and would transfer to us as an
inheritance
since it doesn't go to probate
yeah i would make sure to look into that
work with an estate attorney or tax pro
to make sure that your plan is going to
work out the way you think it will
right
but outside of that it doesn't sound
like there's much need to keep this
house it doesn't sound like it's going
to appreciate and value or anything like
that you're not going to rent it out so
if i'm you guys you're going to take the
150k and split the money at that point
well if my father dies that's definitely
what we'll do with it but yeah um we
we're just curious whether we should try
and keep it as an inheritance or whether
we should sell it for his care um
well right now it sounds like there's
some things in flux with not knowing
what's going to happen with dad so i
don't think you need to be in a rush to
make this move but i think once the dust
is settled and we figure out what's
happening here i would sell it and use
that money to either help take care of
him or use it as a blessing of an
inheritance you know if and when he does
pass i appreciate the call this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
paying off debt is smart
saving and investing is smart
but there's one key to winning with
money that people overlook all the time
and that is protecting your finances
from emergencies that's where insurance
comes into play now there are 10 kinds
of insurance coverage you might need
based on what your life looks like today
and so we built a tool called the
coverage checkup to show you exactly
which types you need to add drop or
adjust we'll even rank your coverage
list by importance we'll email it to you
and connect you with a ramsey trusted
insurance provider so that you can get
your plan in place fast seriously this
could be the most important five minutes
you spend today
one of our fans donald wrote in and i
like how he put this for anyone who has
not completed this checkup do it now you
never know when something will happen
and you never want to leave your family
in a bad situation visit ramsay
solutions dot com slash checkup to take
our quick coverage checkup that's ramsay
solutions dot com slash checkup do not
let an emergency sneak up on you protect
your family now
sarah joins us on the line from calgary
alberta sarah i see on my screen it says
you are debt free
yes hi george it's a pleasure to be
speaking with you today you as well
congratulations
thank you so much how much debt did you
pay off
63 000. all right and how long did this
take
18 months of gazelle intensity
crushed it okay and what was your range
of income during that time
so i started off um just graduating from
university i was making about 25k and
canadian dollars obviously and now i'm
up to about 75k wow way to go what do
you do for a living
um so i do still work at a retail store
so i do sales but then i got a full-time
job working a 9-5 as an executive
recruiter oh that's fantastic
and how old are you
i'm 24. oh my goodness you got a hold of
this stuff at the right time
good for you yeah
so what kind of debt was the 63 000
um a mix of everything i had my student
loans i had a car loan credit card line
of credit um really anything i could get
my hands on wow
so this is interesting you were very
normal you had all kinds of debt you
were collecting it like it was beanie
babies back in the 90s what happened 18
months ago where you said you know what
no more debt no more games
yeah um so i graduated university in
april of 2020 and that was then you know
covet is is kind of taking off and i had
really wanted to move out of my parents
house and when i started to think about
how i couldn't afford rent i really
couldn't afford to do anything i needed
to make a plan get a job and and really
buckle down and and lastly in canada we
got a bit of financial support as i was
somebody who was affected by coveton in
terms of um being a front line worker
dare i say i'm not a health care worker
but in in a retail and so they allowed
us to kind of take some time away and
with that help from the government and
then finding dave ramsey i i really just
realized how debt free is the way to go
wow so how'd you get connected to us
what was the thing where you went oh i
didn't know about this plan
yeah i i heard about dave ramsey growing
up a little bit but my parents are not
people who talk about money a bunch so i
remember you know in april of 2020 being
so stressed and every day i'm waking up
thinking like where am i how am i going
to pay these bills how am i going to
shuffle that around and then i was
looking on youtube like hey
advice to get debt free and obviously
dave ramsey is one of the top and so i
probably went
days on end watching almost every video
i could every podcast and just really
being like wow listen to all these
stories and the changes it's made and
and so honestly yeah just youtube and
social media connected wow you just went
all in our youtube guy in the booth zach
he's going crazy he loves it that's what
we like to see life change see youtube
can be used for good if it's in the
right hands
way to go so what were the sacrifices
you made you said you were gazelle
intense what did that look like for you
uh well one thing at home i'm lucky that
my parents didn't make me pay rent but
it comes at a different cost of um you
know situation and then feeling like an
i'm an adult but i still live with my
parents and
i started to do a lot of free stuff so
my boyfriend and i would go disc golfing
or just go for walks and and so i had to
miss out on some plans i i didn't take a
grad trip because i couldn't afford it
and it was also kovitz but that helped
as well but really just kind of you know
missing out on dinners and not ordering
big stuff when i did go out and and
staying at home
wow and i see your list here if you're
watching on youtube you have things to
look forward to if i save was that did
you kind of have that as your why you
kind of dangle that in front of you
saying hey i want dogs i want to go to
hawaii i want to own a house i have
dreams here
yeah exactly that and and so i just had
that posted at right beside my bedroom
door so every time i left and came in it
was right there and one day you know
this door frame is going to be yours one
day you get to have a dog running with
you and one day you do that grad trip to
hawaii and it's going to feel so much
better debt-free wow that's a mature
place to be when you realize you know
what i'm just saying no right now
because a lot of people your age they go
well dave doesn't want me to have stuff
he doesn't want me to eat out he doesn't
want me to go on trips he's just a fuddy
duddy and you realized no i'm saying no
right now so i can say yes to the next
exactly
exactly i'm so proud of you way to go
how does it feel to be debt-free
it it is incredible like i kind of
mentioned i i honestly used to wake up
every day and think about like how am i
gonna move dead around to pay my
insurance or pay my car note or my
student loans are now you know adding to
my budget or air quota on budget at the
time but it was so stressful and at such
a young age and now i i wake up and and
even a couple weeks ago i had a car
emergency that cost me two grand but
because i have savings and because i
have a good job it was just like okay
fix the car and pay the bill and and
you're okay
and moved on yeah
yeah
that's incredible
so did people think you were crazy for
doing this stuff i don't know what
canada's vibe is on the ramsey plan but
do you have people who are like what are
you doing why are you paying that off i
mean it'll get forgiven eventually
yeah so i'm not aware that we have like
as much as a forgiveness program as you
know people talk about in america but i
definitely had family who is like well
everybody's in debt like there's no
that's just the way it is like you have
to have a bill you have to do this and
um yeah there's definitely people who
just thought it was strange and and
luckily i was able to you know my
boyfriend was a huge support to me and
my dad was a huge support to me he was
really operational and making sure i
didn't have to pay rent while i was
going through this but a lot of other
people in my life were like okay well
good luck like you're probably going to
go into debt again anyway and i'm like
no i'm
man they must be real fun at parties
yeah exactly right
so so you've done this stuff you're 24
you paid off 63 000 in 18 months what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
i would definitely say one having a
support like i know i used to
emotionally shop and that's what added
to a lot of my debt but kind of talking
about that and especially with my
partner he's been so supportive through
this and and saying like listen i'm
having a tough day and i i want to go
shopping i want to do this and he would
be able to find different ways for us to
do fun things and kind of help me feel
better and so a good support system i
think is a huge part of it and and then
the other part is that you know if you
can work two or three jobs like that's
what i had to do and and it's only for a
moment a season is what i love to hear
from you guys and once the season is
done then you get to live and give like
nobody else and so i'm really looking
forward to that time in my life and um
yeah just work when you can however you
can wherever you can it's going to be a
lot but it's going to be so worth it man
well said well it's amazing what happens
when you get a fire in your belly and
you're not afraid to work and you're not
afraid to create some discipline in your
life and you say no to things and i saw
on my screen you said you cannot afford
another shirt you have that at the
bottom of your debt list to encourage
yourself that you can't afford this you
can't afford to be broke it's very
expensive to be broke
exactly and no matter how many shirts
you have in your closet you're still
broke
wow
that was a personal attack on many of
our listeners
i love it well we're so proud of you
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you and number one
national bestseller that is absolutely
the next step in your journey at 24
years old with no payments you're going
to do so unbelievably well and be so
wealthy and so generous and we also have
a copy of the total money makeover to
send to you you can pass that along to
one of those people who said you're
crazy and that you're always going to
have payments and you can you can pass
that to them to go no it can be
different for you
we're so proud of you are you ready for
this
yes okay it's sarah from calgary alberta
63 000
paid off student loans the car loan the
credit cards the line of credit you name
it she had it paid it off in 18 months
making 25 to 75. count it down sarah
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one i'm dead
[Music]
there it is
there it is
wow if sarah can do it you can too
america it's not too late for you i
don't care if you're 24 44 64. you can
take control this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell ramsay personality
you are listening to the ramsay show
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five
steve joins us in kansas city steve
welcome to the ramsay show
[Music]
well thank you george good talking to
you i was looking for the better than i
deserved um oh man if i tried that steve
you wouldn't understand the hate mail
that would come my way you know
but one of these days i'll risk it
well hey george we got a quick question
for you
so here's my scenario i
i'm in my early 50s okay and so i've got
a home
with a 95 000 home payoff
i've got right at seven years left to
pay on the home
i have about 85 000 in savings
my question really is
the friends i have that are into big
intense investing
i have one friend that says pay the
house off don't even question it
and for the guys that say oh no you want
to use their money at 2.5 percent to pay
the home off
and then use the 80 000 and invest it
because you can double that in seven
years and that's about the time i got my
house to pay off
so when i do the math
and if i just completely pay it off
by each payment
i am at 145.
so if i look at that i pay an extra 45
or 50 basically
you see what i'm saying i do the math
and then oh sure i have 85 in there yeah
no this is uh
yeah they're they're not geniuses they
just are looking strictly at math and
that's the problem here uh you can't you
can't
you know detach the emotion out of this
of the emotion of not having a payment
in the world having zero risk because
you own your home outright so what's
your mortgage payment
it's right at 1952 a month 1952.
so let me give you some more math for
your buddies if they're listening
you are paying currently uh almost 24
000 in mortgage payments and that does
not count the interest
so the question is if you had an extra
24 000 plus
to invest how wealthy could you become
i'm right there with you that's how i
feel about it i mean i'm just saying if
we want to talk strictly math that's not
even talking about the emotional freedom
of having not a payment in the world so
i understand what your buddies are
saying and they're really into investing
and so of course they think well why
wouldn't you borrow as much money as
possible and invested into the market
that's what they're saying but as we're
seeing with the stock market i don't i
mean do you want that level of anxiety
would you if you paid off your house you
can always go remortgage it and invest
into the market if you really really
miss having a payment
right
and the way the market is right now it's
kind of how i'm feeling
get debt free first and then i can
invest as much as i can afford at that
point
exactly i want you to free up this money
in your life so that you can really
build wealth so that you don't have to
worry about a payment at night
and what's your household income
so give or take um we're right at 200
000 take home whoo
man are you guys baby steps millionaires
well
it's funny you say that i have uh i have
my brand new book setting here now we've
always been pretty smart with our money
we we don't have we we have
zero debt other than the mortgage
fantastic so i just got i just got the
book though and i'm going uh i'm getting
into this um
so we have oh i'm gonna say it's right
in 7.50 in
in retirement awesome right now
so i'm thinking if i pay this off this
year which i think is very doable
then i just invest like crazy right and
now i can't afford to then
yeah and we're already putting in 15 of
our tax deferred
income as well yeah you're already doing
the 15
so let's focus on the house payoff and
do you have kids that you're saving for
college for
well we have one and unfortunately
session does not want to do college so
okay i do have some money i have some
money saved for her
and we have some other ideas as far as
starting the business and that so
cool
you know i have mixed emotions about
that but uh that's where that's at all
right well hey if i'm you you got 85 000
in savings and we need to make sure
we're setting aside our fully funded
emergency fund is that part of the 85
no we've got about 20 000 in an
emergency fund so you could today
get down to 10 000 on the mortgage and
then clean this thing up within a month
or two with your income that's what i'm
thinking yeah and i've got some
commissions i did i got a lot of
equipment on order
and gosh i've got in the neighborhood of
175 000 commissions coming wow this year
without selling one more thing so i
think this is a no-brainer it absolutely
is don't listen to your your buddies man
they of course are going to look at the
market and go dude you're an idiot why
would you pay off your two percent
mortgage when you could make 10 12 18 of
the market
exactly yeah well you can follow their
plan or you could be debt-free including
your mortgage and uh personally i like
that plan better as a guy who paid his
off a month ago
okay let me ask you this
if i put in and i'm just going to do
some simple math but if i put in oh my
gosh and just invest like crazy because
i really like to
do something a little different when i'm
60 and i'm 54 now
could i get to that million dollar mark
i would think so if i'm 7.50 in now
already oh absolutely plus the home
you're going to be there in no time
making 200k i mean think about how much
you can save and the catch-up amounts uh
with your age as you head into your
retirement you're going to be
unbelievably wealthy
i think so too within seven years yeah
so i'm not worried about can we make can
we make an extra 50 grand by investing
in the market you're going to do fine in
retirement if you guys have no payment
in the world including your mortgage
and you got a million dollars in
retirement you're going to be all right
thank god listen to your heart steve i
appreciate the call man good stuff all
right trey joins us in pittsburgh trey
welcome to the ramsay show
hey george thanks for taking my call how
you doing absolutely doing great how can
i help today
um i have a question about 529s um
i have two kids ages are five and two
um
when my first kid was born
probably about six months ever after she
was born we went to the bank and started
a 529 account awesome we've put 250 a
month in it
since then
um at the birth of our second child
my wife and i had
a conversation about
starting a second 529 for him
we went to the bank and they kind of
advised us to
keep it at
just a single 529
and could get the compounding interest
off of what's being put in that
it's always been like a conversation
between my wife and i
should we or shouldn't we have started a
second 25 29 for him as well
um just trying to get your thoughts on
it yeah i would i would not look to my
bank to be my financial advisor and so
in this case uh they're wrong i mean
there's nothing wrong with keeping one
but it does complicate things a little
bit because when you have one plan
you're gonna have to go through some
administrative legwork of changing
beneficiaries because you can only have
one beneficiary on that 529 and so as
the five-year-old gets older you're
gonna have to switch it over to the
two-year-old and make sure there's
enough money in there to regulate you
know how much money is needed per child
and on top of that there could be some
state tax deductions and credits that
increase when you have multiple accounts
so no the bank is wrong they don't
understand compound interest which
really frightens me that a bank doesn't
understand that that hundred dollars
over here versus in your other account
is going to grow at the same rate
yeah
and so if i have two roth iras and i put
5 000 in each it makes no difference if
i had a roth ira that had 10 000 won
yeah yeah exactly and uh and my wife had
brought up a good point she's she had
said with the ages of the kids they're
both going to be in college at the same
time
if they choose to go to college yeah and
that creates a habit
yes yep okay yeah that was my question
and uh she was right i hate to tell her
that but she was right that you know
what that is a sign of maturity and a
healthy marriage i appreciate the call
trey uh pump for those kids to go to
college debt free that is what we like
to see around here and if you guys
haven't tuned into the borrowed future
documentary uh we did a world-class
documentary that released back in the
fall
around the student loan crisis and how
it is absolutely crushing the american
dream as one of my passions is helping
millennials and gen z figure out that
man you are going to be saddled with
debt don't listen to the lies don't fall
for the peer pressure for society you
can go to college debt free and you're
living proof of that tray way to go
saving up for them
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books our thanks to ben hill
running the board today kelly daniel our
associate producer and jenna sears
running the screening of the phones we
appreciate you and appreciate you
america we'll be back with you before
you know it
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
george campbell ramsay personality and
it's an open free call today for you
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five maybe you need
some confirmation about a life decision
you're facing maybe you had a windfall
of money that's always a fun one we can
talk about that maybe you're sick of
making payments to lenders and you wish
you had that money back in your life to
help you accomplish your dreams
not the banks we can talk about that too
it's your show
brie kicks us off this hour from bend
oregon brie welcome to the ramsay show
hi george thanks so much for taking my
call i'm a big fan oh and i do need
confirmation on a big life decision
perfect i prophesied it how can i help
yes
so we are just to clarify we're in a
very very small town just outside of
bend um and it's so it's kind of a
special situation and i'll try to point
as quickly as possible um basically it's
a small town of like 160 people that's
surrounded completely by farmland so
it's not you can't develop it anymore
around this small town so we have an
option to buy a larger home meets our
needs more
it's a great place for us
however um that the price is going up in
the market my husband's struggling
because he feels like we could build
exactly what we would want for the same
price if we had a place to do it however
so in theory he might be right but in
reality there's no place at this time
for us for a lifestyle to build because
there's no option
and so i guess my question is
do we
take this opportunity because there's
things about the house he doesn't
absolutely love and me i'm trying to
really work on contentment and be okay
with the things and if we don't love it
we can fix it over time um but it's a
newer house and it's a great house it's
just
that that in his mindset struggling
you know to to say you know for that
same price we could do exactly what we
want and pick everything out and and so
i guess i don't want to miss an
opportunity with the market going up and
everything it's just a
big decision and i need advice i guess
yeah so let me get this straight he
wants to build kind of the dream home
and you're saying hey there's a great
house over here and we can make it that
we can fix it up over time but he's
saying no that's a waste let's just
build our dream home
well he he would love to if we could but
and so i guess in my reality it could be
if things were ever to be able to be
developed it could be five ten years
before an actual lot even was an option
so i mean he's right and i'd love to
build two but so his plan is a pipe
dream that sounds like it's not even
feasible unless you guys moved
to a different town correct and we can't
move with our jobs okay well it's it
sounds like there's not really options
here there's only one
yeah so we'll just stay where we're at
and be in a smaller house that doesn't
really meet our lifestyle needs i guess
and so there lies the predicament this
sounds more like you need to get him on
the same page and not move into this
house and he's just walking around
resentful going uh i hate this place
right right
that's it i think he would be over time
i think it's just he's more frugal and
you know and so i understand where
you're coming from it's just it's it's
like we have this opportunity and i
don't want to miss it if we can jump on
it well i wouldn't worry about the
market i mean yes home value will
appreciate over time
but don't let that dictate what you're
doing right now let your finances your
budget dictate so where are you guys at
financially are you out of debt do you
have an emergency fund are you investing
um we are well we are investing we're
pretty much out of debt except right now
with this limbo phase we we can pay it
all off we just want to let the dust
settle if we do the house thing and then
pay off as soon as we move in once the
dust bottles oh boy okay brie i was
really on your team here and now we got
to take a time out
we got to clean up
and we probably should just do it now
and then move in it's just yeah
definitely how much debt how much debt
do you have what's the total amount
well like five thousand okay what's your
household income
130 130 ish
so this thing's paid off
within 30 days it's gone
yes absolutely but you're hanging on
because well we just don't know what
life's gonna look like
well it's just one of those like you
know like moving babies i just kind of
scared me just knowing that we have
opportunity but um but it is it is a big
priority for us and really taking care
of it and we do invest in um where we're
so it's just the most
you need to do it quickly and we will do
you have a fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months
yes so you have that and you're
investing so you just kind of leap frog
baby step two and went let's do three
four and we'll come we'll come back
around to two
well we and that's the thing we it's
just this in this moment we were you
know just in this very so it is a
i promise they were paying it off
well once that's paid off that'll free
your income up a little bit because
you're not going to have those payments
which is going to allow you to save up
more so if you guys looked at what the
down payment's going to look like for
this house
yes and we're ready for that we can
definitely afford it and do those
less than 25
awesome so 15 are you doing a 15-year
fixed
yes okay and it's a payment's less than
25 of your take-home pay that's awesome
and how much down payment are you
looking to put down
about 40.
awesome
you guys are crushing it
thank you we're trying well and once you
do that remind your husband that you're
going to have lots of margin to be able
to fix up this house
and you can do it over time and the
angrier the more angry he is at this the
more it's going to be all right well
let's get a side job let's make some
sacrifices let's dig in to make these
renovations happen faster so that he can
love it i mean is it cosmetic or is it
just every it's everything
i'm just a in some is and some isn't but
some of it i feel like again it comes
back to being contentment you know and
just being like this is a really big
deal in the scheme of things you know
yeah well it sounds like he had a
picture in his mind of what this house
was going to be
and because it's not that he just cannot
grapple with the reality
yeah
definitely so he needs to compromise my
scene for 20. yeah my my thing for 22 is
contentment and so i'm really trying to
be like you know this is a great
opportunity
even though it's not maybe not perfect
but most houses even i feel like
sometimes even if you build a brand new
house there's going to be things you
find that you wish you would have done
differently oh absolutely and i'll tell
them i we built our house that is now
paid off and it's not our dream house
it's not perfect the construction
process was a nightmare things went
wrong we had to stay on them it was a
legit side job of just keeping up with
this house walking in there going oh
gosh they didn't put the towel rack
where they said they would oh gosh they
chose the wrong grout color i mean
there's a thousand things that you know
i love new construction but it can be a
big headache and so
there's a lot of perks of just moving
into a house that you know exactly what
you're getting and you know exactly what
to fix
so i think some of this contentment
needs to rub off on him
so
you guys work on that have you been
through fpu together have you gone
through financial peace university as a
couple
um
separately we kind of we well not the
official press but we followed it um our
own
years ago yeah well that's going to be
my gift to you jenna's going to pick up
i'm going to gift you a year
subscription to ramsey plus and what i
encourage you guys to do is get plugged
into the every dollar plus budgeting app
get plugged into the financial peace
university videos and get on the same
page about your vision for the future
that's what i think needs to happen
right now because truthfully they're
you're in separate places he wants one
thing you're okay with this thing with
contentment i want you guys to dream
together and get excited about what that
future holds and if that means it's
house renovations right now then you go
full chip and joanna and you have a
blast right that's what this looks like
but right now this is it's as much a
marital problem as it is a financial one
so get this thing right get them on the
same page jenna will pick up and it is
our gift to you to get plugged into
ramsay plus for the year so that you can
guys make that progress and do it
together as one team
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let me ask you a question when you think
of a millionaire what kind of job do you
picture them having
is it some kind of high-powered
executive position like a vp or a ceo
well here's the thing
only 15
of millionaires actually have jobs like
that the reality is that the top five
careers for millionaires in america are
as follows engineer
accountant teacher
manager and attorney that's just one of
the surprising things our team found out
when we conducted the largest studies of
millionaires ever done we talked to tens
of thousands of millionaires to find out
who they are and how they achieved that
goal our study also made it clear that
to become a millionaire you've got to
invest wisely and a big part of that is
getting good investing advice not from
your broke bros telling you to invest in
crypto
you've got to work with an investing pro
who can walk with you and teach you
about the options that are right for you
our team recommends vetted trustworthy
investing pros from all over the country
we call them smart vester pros and if
you want to get in touch with a smart
investor pro in your area we make it
really easy just go to
ramseysolutions.com
smart vester and you can start building
wealth today that's ramsay
slash smart vester
rachel joins us in billings montana
rachel welcome to the ramsay show
hi there thank you absolutely how can i
help today
we're coming into a large sum of money
about a hundred thousand from a debt
owed to us
and while the lump sum is great
the debtor was previewed previously
paying us about a thousand dollars a
month
which
we rely on to meet our monthly
obligations
we have one debt it's our home
the hundred thousand is not quite enough
to pay that off which would be the easy
fix because then it would free up money
and we'd be just fine
so i'm looking for some advice or
thoughts on a good way to allocate that
100k in a way that will help us to
continue
to meet our monthly obligations that
aren't debts
but they're nonetheless yeah great
questions you have some ideas so this
thousand dollars a month you said that
you were relying on this
without this are you guys way too tight
on the budget
it will be tight i think we'll be about
400 short
um
and i
and that's not to say i do feel like we
could make some cuts
but that's what kind of gets us down to
the 400. we have a big family
uh seven great kids
six of them live with us and
my oldest has some really severe special
needs another daughter with
oh you know medical bills are a big
chunk of that yeah yeah this is so
you're saying there's not a lot of uh
frivolous spending happening in the
budget you know i i hesitate to say that
there's always room to tighten the bill
my husband's a school teacher and i stay
home and take care of our our oldest son
but we are very blessed so i don't want
to give the impression that we're
in bloom what's your household income
our household income is about i'm into
80 000 a year my husband's a hard worker
and he supplements that a lot in the
summer that's awesome no good man yeah
it is i said we're very blessed
so what's left on the mortgage
150 thousand hundred years
yeah okay
and you guys are you're out of debt
completely except a home do you have a
fully funded emergency fund
we have about two thousand dollars in an
emergency fund
okay feels like we need to up that for a
family of seven what would three to six
months of expenses look like for you
guys if you put a number on it a lot
more than that
20 grand well our expenses are about
i'm just doing some quick math about
four thousand a month
okay
so we're looking at three months would
be 12 and because it's he's the only
um you know earning income in the house
it feels like you want to lean towards
six when you got seven kids you got
special needs so that looks more like
twenty four thousand dollars
yeah probably so i feel very happy
inside to have that there we go this is
what i want for you happiness freedom
so
outside of that is your husband
investing 15 of his income into
retirement
you know no not safer than what his
employment invests he's like say the
school teacher and uh they fully fund
his retirement
so there's a mandatory kind of
contribution that they're they're
putting in from their money not his yes
no they pay his contribution they pay
his part okay their part and then they
pay him
well i want to encourage him to to begin
investing 15 of the income i know it
feels tight right now but there's a lot
of there's a lot of variables in this
situation what's that
my scary part for me is i know
we have to pay our bills and without
being able to eliminate those
we do have some pieces of property and
stuff maybe we should
again it wouldn't fix the we don't quite
have enough to pay off the home
you know we probably have about fifteen
thousand dollars in a little
little chunk of land down the street
it's not doing anything it's just
sitting there you're just paying
property taxes on it for fun
we do it's not a lot we're in a real
rural area but it is 500 a year
nothing nothing major okay well it's not
breakfast as far as this lump sum i
would go ahead and i would take you know
if you have two thousand dollars i would
go ahead and take 22 000 and add it to
that savings account to give you a fully
funded emergency fund
now that leaves you with 76 000
and the truth is i want you to pay down
the house paying down the house is not
going to solve all of your problems it's
not going to create any extra cash flow
for you right now
yeah and but i still want it to go
towards the house that should still be
your next goal obviously we need to be
you know funding college if that's on
the table for all of these kids is that
is that part of the conference
pay for their own
you just said you're on your own
you know they've so far they've paid
they've paid for their own i have one
married daughter and uh two 19 year old
boys that are placed in their missions
for our church but um when they get back
and pick up their college again though
they'll have to pay for themselves i
think unless we get really rich between
now and then hey i want that for you and
it can happen i mean you guys aren't
you're not doing bad i want you to
realize that you're not in a destitute
situation losing this thousand dollars a
month
yeah i know it's like a mixed blessing i
feel it's a blessing i just i don't know
what to do with it
yeah well i mean if i if i'm you guys
i'm going to follow the baby steps and
you could put a chunk away for college
but if you've already had the
conversation and you said hey kids
you're on your own and they they
understand that and they know hey we're
not going to go into debt we're not
going to do student loans but you've got
to figure out a way
then then you're moving on to baby step
six which is paying off the home early
and so you're gonna knock out half of
the mortgage leaving you guys with 74
000 on the mortgage
are you putting any extra on the
mortgage beyond the payment we aren't we
aren't okay we aren't right now
i'm not sure we have the best interest
rate um i don't know what are you at
right now do you know
oh we're at 4.5
yeah i mean i are you on a 30 year
no we did a 10 year oh a 10 year okay
well i mean you could refinance
obviously look at the break-even
analysis on that and figure out okay if
we're going to pay 5000 in closing costs
how quickly are we going to make up for
that with the lower interest rate and i
like it for to be two years or less
three max and so you can look at that as
an option um to see especially once you
have a 75 000 mortgage if you can
refinance on that your payment's gonna
shrink
you know i didn't think about that but
little bank refinance i i feel really
unwilling to go longer than 10.
i bet maybe i'm maybe that's not the
right thinking maybe i need to say yeah
we'll refinance for 10 and do the 75 and
then we can meet that obligation right
you can do better than that i think we
can we need to work on this budget are
you guys doing a household budget every
month on paper and tracking you like you
do down to the penny wow way to go
look i would do an audit of that and go
hey are we getting the best rates on our
insurance are we getting the best rate
over here do we need the subscription
right now and i think cutting this
temporarily and having that emergency
fund in place you're going to feel such
a weight off of your shoulders because
you are you are super mom right now
you're incredible i don't know we're
trying like everybody around us we're
trying to do our best
well just know that that we are we are
rooting for you we are in your corner
appreciate that i would definitely
pay down the house look at refinance
after that and see if it makes sense for
you and tighten up that budget but right
now there's not a lot of other options
you you can't go to work yeah well if
you give me some things to think about
though i i like the idea maybe
refinancing the 75 and definitely like
the idea of the emergency fund so maybe
i'll just get brave and say we're doing
it
i love it well thank you so much for the
call
we are in your corner man seven kids i
cannot imagine i've got two dogs at home
and i feel overwhelmed i've got nothing
to complain about
wow
good times this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast and i've got a
special guest for you this segment one
of our newest personalities christina
ellis joins me christina how are you i'm
doing great thanks for having me so
you've been on the team now uh since
october yeah a few months in how you
feeling i'm loving it i just crossed my
90 day mark so i'm feeling pretty good
that's awesome yeah well we are so
excited to have you on the team to help
us disrupt this toxic culture around
student loans higher education
and parents and society and guidance
counselors there's like a thousand
villains that you can point at in this
situation oh yeah it's it's crazy right
now
debt has been so normalized in this
space we are selling 18 year olds debt
where they think that taking out student
loans that it's just normal that it's
just part of the process and that's not
okay i'm so proud of the work that
ramsey's done with borrowed future and
just
bringing light to that situation it
really disrupts that toxic culture and
it shows students you know this is not
the way to go and there are other ways
that we can fix this yeah there's
definitely a lie that was sold at least
to me and i know many many people out
there where we as a society we said hey
if you just do really good in school and
you get great grades you'll have an
amazing life you'll go to your dream
school and life's gonna work out for you
but unfortunately as you realize you i i
wanted to go to the school and i got in
and i thought oh my gosh i gotta prove
to my dream school and i got zero
dollars and it was 200 000 for the four
years for
basically a film degree
and even not knowing dave back then i
was like this feels like a bad deal for
me i'm not doing this so i ended up
going to a state school i was out of
school for a year went back to school
finished up and still ended up with 36
000 in student loans and i thought well
i did better than 200 grand
that's the thing is i talk to students
all the time who just kind of shrug off
student loans like ah yeah it's no big
deal it's what everybody's doing it's
what all of my friends are doing and
it's important to highlight like it
doesn't have to be that way you know my
story i won a half a million dollars in
scholarships i was able to go to school
debt-free my mom really lit a fire in me
early she basically said my freshman
year you know christina you're on your
own for paying for college so you need
to figure out a strategy and i'm so
thankful she had that conversation early
on because it gave me time to think
about what i was doing and try to see
like are there other ways i can go to
college do i have to follow this notion
that you have to take out student loans
and i learned that you don't yeah it
really comes down to having a plan
having a strategy and having the
conversation early i mean we just i just
took a call
and she's got seven kids and she was
very honest with them and she said hey
you're on your own but i appreciate that
honesty versus i will figure it out
figure it out and what figuring it out
looks like is co-signing hundreds of
thousands of dollars in loans and then
everyone's frustrated absolutely not a
solution yeah it's a tough pill to
swallow you know to tell your kids you
know we can't afford college it's hard
you know when my mom told me freshman
year of high school i was like why are
you telling me this i am a freshman what
can i do about it but at the same time
you know i knew she was just trying to
be real with me you know my dad he
passed away when i was seven from cancer
and my family struggled financially so
even though it was tough like i'm
thankful she had the courage to have
that conversation because it just it
needs to happen that conversation
doesn't need to be had with somebody
selling your students student loans oh
yeah it needs to happen with parents
yeah well we have a high school
curriculum out there uh through our
ramsay education team and i got the
pleasure of hosting it and it was so eye
opening as i sat down with high
schoolers and i was asking them basic
questions where do you want to go to
school what do you want to do how much
do you think that'll pay how much will
that school cost and i didn't realize it
was going to be an interrogation there
were kids running out of there crying
after we were done and i thought oh my
gosh i'm the first one to ask them these
questions their parents are not talking
to them about the future they're just
going la la la la i have shame and guilt
and baggage for my own financial past
and we're just not going to talk about
money because that's that's the healthy
way to to handle our families and having
that conversation as much as it might be
painful man it's so freeing in your
situation where you went okay at least i
know what i need to do now right exactly
a lot of kids don't have that wisdom and
insight early on even just career-wise a
lot of students think you know i have to
go to the fancy school if i'm going to
be successful like i have to go to a
name-brand school and a lot of those
schools cost seventy thousand dollars um
and that's just not true you know if you
walk around ramsey it's a competitive
workplace you know we have amazing
people here and if you ask people where
they went to school a lot of people went
to community college a lot of people
went to an online school a lot of people
you know just took non-traditional
routes and they're still here working
next to people who did go to prestigious
schools so you know the reality is that
you don't have to go to the fancy school
to be successful that is true all across
workplaces in america you'll have
somebody sitting at a desk that went to
an ivy league and you'll have somebody
sitting right next to them that went to
community college so you have to just
find your own path to success that's
debt free oh yeah and these days with
the digital space that we live in
there's just so many opportunities i
mean mit has so many free courses out
there where you're learning the same
things that you would inside of the
classroom that would cost you you know
thousands upon thousands of dollars
right and now there's amazing
certificate programs you know there's
digital marketing certificate programs
there's all sorts of like coding boot
camps and things that you can do online
that'll get you incredible jobs that
make great money so it's like think
outside of the box explore your options
there's not just one right path yeah and
that's one of those things that we need
to keep beating the drum on because
students do think well if i don't go to
college i'm a nobody like all of my
friends went and here i am in my in my
town and i'm just not going to have a
great life now
well what's crazy is that trade school
that's still a great option the trades
are not going away and the thing is is
no matter how hard the economy gets no
matter what the world looks like we
still need electricians we still need
plumbers so it's like college isn't the
only right route it's the right route
for a lot of people but the right route
for a lot of people is also going to be
trade school it's going to be all these
different options that are out there so
it's important to figure out you know
what is right for you what is right for
your student even if it doesn't look
like what everybody else does yeah and
one of the problems is we live in such a
comparison culture and it's so it's so
much about your your status and social
media and what i'm seeing is the number
one job that students want is to be an
influencer and to be a youtuber and
while that's great that they want to
have an impact in that way and they want
to be front and center that's fine you
know we're we're on camera we're in
front of microphones there's nothing
wrong with with wanting that but i
question the motive behind it and the
heart behind it and going man what do
you really want what do you really want
to apply full force in your life what do
you want to dig into what is the topic
what is the area of focus and once you
ask those questions you can get to some
really interesting answers right exactly
i also think like speaking of comparison
i think a lot of parents fall into the
comparison trap you know i've heard
parents talk to me and complain to me
that you know in the high school
environment all these parents are
talking about well where's your kid
going to school my kids going to an ivy
league my kids going to this fancy
school and they almost feel pressure to
have their kid go somewhere fancy or to
sign on the dotted line for a parent
that's so toxic that the parents are
using their their kids as a pawn to
elevate their status
or i went to this school therefore my
kid needs to go to this school too
because this is our legacy and they're
going for the football team and they're
going because of the landscaping and the
water slides and the world-class
cafeteria and we've lost our daggum
minds yeah there's just so much toxic
pressure in this space and what results
is student loans like that's what
happens when we don't have these
conversations about you know what's
actually going on and the challenges you
know people just end up getting kind of
roped in to that trap yeah so what can
parents do if you're a parent listening
out there and you're going all right
christina i haven't saved for my kids
college i got to have this conversation
saying i can't i can't do this i can't
cash flow it for you what would you say
to that parent well the fact that they
even want to have real conversations
about
money with their kids that's amazing
there are so many parents that are
scared to have that conversation or they
just don't think about having that
conversation so let your kids know what
they're going to be up against
financially you know have those real
conversations about where you guys are
what what are they going to be
responsible for when it comes to college
and their future and then take debt off
the table like you be the first person
to tell your kids we're not doing debt
like we're going to go a different
direction like that's not what we're
doing and then help them cast a vision
for their life i think a lot of kids you
know they leave high school and they
don't really know what they want to do
so it's so they're vulnerable when
they're out there but you know help them
cast a vision and connect the dots of
like what does it take to get there you
know they may not need a four-year
degree they may not need a master's
degree they may need that trade
certificate you know there's so many
different routes that just really lock
arms arms with them and help them figure
out what works for them i love it
christine ellis folks one of our newest
ramsay personalities focused on this
toxic student loan crisis you can see
her in our borrowed future documentary
you can stream that on apple tv google
play amazon you name it christina so
awesome having you on the team thanks
for having me i'm so thrilled to be here
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell you jump in america and
we'll talk about your life and your
money the number to call is triple eight
eight two five
five two two five
steve joins us from green bay wisconsin
steve welcome to the ramsay show
my afternoon sir how are you doing how
can i help
oh i'm doing great
another day being alive it's a good
thing i love that attitude
just got a question for you
um
i'm i turned uh 60 back over six seven
months ago we got about 80 some thousand
left on our house
um
and i'm just kind of curious
if it would be wise to take
money
that we have set aside from our 401k and
stuff to pay off the house and be
debt-free
so how much is in the retirement account
um
roughly
well i don't depend on the market keeps
going if it keeps pulling away it's not
going to be much uh about 750
000 okay and is that everything you have
saved for retirement
yep all right and you're still working
yep what's your household income
before taxes just around 50.
50 before tax okay and you have no other
debt you just have this mortgage payment
you have a savings account with three to
six months of expenses
uh
yes
there was some i i want some i want
confidence here steve do you have it
wait yes yes we do uh i got about
roughly about 20 20 000 set aside okay
good but i was kind of thinking
to take that and then some of the money
from the 401k oh dear pay off the house
no no no steve well you're saying you're
retired right i mean you're still
working you can take this money out
penalty free
yep
i mean it's
if i'm if i'm in your shoes i definitely
want to be free of this mortgage and
making 50k how much margin do you have
in your budget every month
yeah
not a lot really
there's not a lot of margin you're
saying if we continue down this path
path i'm not going to be able to pay off
the house anytime soon
if we continue the way we are and if my
plans go that way that
i want to and not the way god wants to
um i could have it paid off in you know
five to six years
okay and do you plan on working for the
next five to six years
uh if i have to if i have the highest
payment probably
yeah
well i want you to have a great
retirement is this everything you have
to your name is the 750 000 plus the
house
yeah what's the house worth
about 300.
okay
so
we're close to baby step billionaire
status if you're not already there with
all of your assets right
yeah way to go man
that's awesome
that's something that i know a few
americans have achieved it's a great
that's a great thing and everything but
you know maybe it's just me and i just
you know
got this debt and i want to get rid of
it because i'm sick and tired of it sure
what's the payment every month
uh
850
okay so not it's not a major part of
your world or even your income at this
point
no and we're paying extra on it every
month as it is okay good good that was
my question is how much margin you had
you know could you just pay this off and
let your retirement sit where it is and
continue to grow but there's nothing
wrong now that you're you can take this
money out penalty free and that'll free
you up i know you're unplugging some of
the the compound growth there but when
you're freed up from that payment
you're going to be able to invest even
more
right would that be your plan yeah
that would be my plan because i'm
thinking you know well
if you could take home you know 30
something a year times five that's 150
000 you know plus the interest yeah
well now that you're of this age i mean
i you know obviously we we tell people
never to take money out of retirement
but you're of retirement age and
therefore now is the time to start to
use this money for your benefit and
getting out of debt including your house
that is one of those benefits so if i'm
in your shoes yes i will take just
enough to get rid of this house payment
and then i'm going to invest like crazy
i'm going to try to increase my income
even as you enter into your 60s and
continue to work i'm going to try to get
that income up so that we can have a
great retirement instead of you know try
to ration it all out even though it's
750. i want it to be million plus
should i just take it from the
retirement fund or should i take what we
have set aside too no i want you don't
touch that because that's your emergency
fund
well i'm you know i'm also thinking too
oh if i get that
take that
unless from the
401k then the emergency fund will get
built up just as quick well i don't want
you to deplete this is not an emergency
you know what i mean this is this is
paying down the house you're going to
get there you're going to build it up
fast but i don't want you to deplete
your emergency fund in order to pay off
the house faster
because then when an emergency hits
you're screwed and so i would take the
exact money out you said you have uh
how much left on that mortgage 80 000
roughly 80 so you're gonna take 80 from
that 750 in the retirement account and
then you're going to invest that new 850
you have back in your life
into
your you can do catch-up contributions
you can invest like a crazy person so
that
you can retire with you know 1.5 million
in five years
that's what i want for you
okay so i was going back and forth on a
couple different ways of doing it i
wasn't sure if it was a good thing to do
or not you know well now that you're of
age there's no penalties that that's
what i would do personally if i was in
your shoe steve get rid of that mortgage
payment and a lot of people may say
that's backwards because you're missing
out on the returns but guess what right
now not a lot of returns to be had so
freeing yourself up from that payment is
going to reduce all of the risk that you
have in your life thanks for the call
jill joins us now in scottsdale arizona
jill welcome to the ramsay show
hi there thanks for having me sure how
can i help hey
well i'm having a car conundrum
um i am one of those folks that teach
their cars forever not that i'm
particularly attached that i just do and
i purchased a car in 2003 at the hummer
it was an h2 i paid cash i was able to
because my grandparents had passed and
left me some money
so i'm at a point now where my car is 18
years old
and every other month stuff is going on
so um
i put a deposit a small deposit down new
homers are coming out i would like to
stick with my brand and you want to
stick with the number okay
yeah it's going to be electric this time
not sure how that's going to work out
but uh after i do my due diligence we'll
see
but i don't know how to go about this
because obviously i can't pay cash like
i did i mean i've worked out about 70
000 for that um
back in 2003 so just trying to figure
out how much to finance and you know if
you know what to pay you know put down
i've got some time before
they're going to be available i believe
2004 early is when they're going to be
available
so you want to start saving yeah i can
simplify this for you you're going to
finance zero dollars
that makes life you're a dollar
yeah
so i want you to pay cash for this car
you don't you do not need to go into
debt for a depreciating asset that's not
going to set you up for success yeah
so how much is this car what's the car
cost
okay it's this time around it's going to
run about 80 85 holy crap what is your
household income
um i pull in a total right now in my new
career so 60 about 61 000 but i've got
um i've got some investment sitting
oh my gosh my head is on the desk
you make 60 000 and you want to buy an
85 000 vehicle
i don't have any debt
it doesn't matter that is more than your
annual income tied up in a depreciating
asset
okay so don't finance pay cash yes
that's and here's the thing
this car is too much of your world our
parameter around vehicles anything with
a motor in it is it should not add up to
more than half of your annual income so
if you're telling me you make 60k we got
to get you a 30k car and now the
situation was different even if you keep
them for 18 years i mean i've only put
10 grand even if you keep them for 18
years you're still gonna get screwed on
this deal and
what i want for you now with the
inheritance that was a different
situation i still would have told you
that's way too much car to be buying and
i know that you see the shiny
commercials and electric oh man it's so
much nicer than mine
but you're just not in a place to do
that for where it makes sense for your
your future and i know you don't have
debt no i understand do you have an
emergency you have to make a lot more
money i used to make a lot more money so
when i changed careers
my income got cut in like half so sure
are you a millionaire my daughter for 10
years
um i was
um and i did stay home with my daughter
for 11 years when she was born so okay i
made that decision and i'm happy i did
but i am in a different position now so
yeah well i appreciate the call i i
definitely would not spend 85 000 on a
car making 60k i want you to pay cash
and do it where it's no more than half
of your income and that means you're
going to look for a great used hummer if
that's what you want that is under 30
grand you can look to the future for
that electric one once it depreciates in
value you can go ahead and buy it
appreciate the call that puts this hour
of the ramsay show in the books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
ramsey personality george campbell and
this is your show america let's talk
money give us a call triple 825-5225
[Music]
john kicks us off this hour in vancouver
canada john welcome to the ramsay show
welcome hello can you hear me sure how
can i help
so i'm planning to buy an electric
vehicle in the near future
okay
it's yeah it'll be my first vehicle
purchase wow
cool how old are you yeah
uh 25 25 okay
have you been driving uh something else
that is not yours yeah my parents cars
yeah okay cool
all right so what's your question
i'm just looking at like because like we
have a carbon tax in canada and it's
like
keeps going up every year you know
that you pay on gas vehicles if you own
a gas vehicle you have to pay an extra
tax
yeah
what is the text you know like
it's
right now it's about 10 cents a liter
okay
for carbon so it keeps going up every
year
and i'm trying to
think about you know switching to an
electric and buying one for myself and
the potential savings and
yeah all right so uh are you
do you have any debt right now
no no i have no debt i have about 50 000
in savings wow
good and another 20 20 000 and
a tax free savings account which is like
a roth ira and then i have another 20
000 and uh rsp which is like a 401k good
for you
man you've been crushing it what do you
do for a living
i work in warehousing i operate a
forklift and do a bunch of distribution
and stuff what's your income
it is right now 60 000
a year okay
and have you researched these electric
vehicles you know which one you want
what the price point would be
uh yes i've looked at i've also looked
at rebates and stuff like for buying
electric vehicles as well
sure both federal and provincial
okay so what's the price of this car if
you went onto the lot and bought it
today without any of the rebates
toyota rav4 prime it's around fifty
thousand dollars
oh boy
yeah dude that's almost your entire
income
tied up in a depreciating asset yeah
were you listening to the last call
no i'm just building my income this is
like not like current years a few years
in the future because it's at least a
one year waiting list for these electric
vehicles okay so you're going to keep
driving your parents car until you
purchase a vehicle
yes and
you're doing this to save money
uh yes yes so we're going to spend 50
000
to save money
in the long term yes
but do you understand
the difference
you could buy a 15 000 car
which means you would have to be paying
35 000 extra in carbon tax and
gas and all of these things in order to
make up for the fact that you bought a
50 000 electric car
no i understand it's not i'm just
looking at all these electric bills
that's why i'm thinking long term not
um
i understand it's thinking long term
we've got to realize that cars are
depreciating asset whether they're gas
or electric
no i understand i don't understand that
well i'm not trying to beat up on you i
just want to think through this
critically with no i know i i that's why
i'm planning like looking at all the
numbers and i just wanted some advice
from your end well we also don't
recommend you buy a new car unless you
are a millionaire
because you can't take the hit on
depreciation making 60k a year buying a
50 000 car that's going to depreciate
every single month yeah and so if i'm
you if you're gonna make 60k let's say a
year from now you're still making about
60k it's not going to go up to 200 000
in warehousing
so what i want you to do is take 30 or
less and buy you a used electric car if
that's something that you're still
wanting
okay i'm just no there's cheaper
electric cars so i'm just looking at all
the ones that have rebate options
but
if you spend 50 grand and get a 5 000
rebate you still spent 45 thousand
dollars
if you bought a twenty thousand dollar
electric car with no rebate you still
saved thirty thousand dollars
do you see the math i'm doing here yeah
you know i know i know so i don't want
your judgment to get clouded by rebates
and credits and
because truthfully it you want the
newest shiny electric vehicle right i
mean who wants to drive a used one if
you could drive a new one
i just don't think the used electric
vehicles are
that plentiful but because there's
already a waiting list for
new electric vehicles in canada or where
i live in vancouver at least
well they're out there you might have to
get there first i mean it's like a hot
home market you just might need to get
there first
and be willing to to negotiate or you
know pay full price or whatever they're
asking but i'm still if i'm you dude
you're just so young you've got your
whole life ahead of you i don't want you
spending all this savings that you've
worked so hard for to go into a
depreciating asset
okay it's gonna be nice as
no i understand i'm just thinking like
from 10 years from now 20 because like
the industry is going to change to the
point where they're going to
only make electric vehicles in 2030 2040
or something well by then we'll all live
on mars and we won't even have to deal
with cars anymore
i'm just saying i don't want you
worrying about what's going to happen 10
years from now i want you to do what's
right for you right now and what makes
sense for your future and right now
you're you're 25 years old you're making
60k you've done really well and i don't
want to see that money disappear into
this electric vehicle because you you
see the shiny lights of credits and
rebates
you know what i mean it still doesn't
make it a wise
i understand i understand it's just i'm
thinking you know this change is going
to happen within my generation within my
lifetime so and when it does we'll deal
with it but right now you can afford 10
cents on a liter even if you didn't get
an electric car
yeah it's just gas is getting up and up
it's like pretty crazy up here now it's
like around five dollars us a gallon
what's your commutes like where are you
going to working back
yeah just to working back what's that
commute
it's like about
it's pretty short like 30 to 50
kilometers
okay something like that is pretty short
yeah well it's not that big you're good
at math you're you're a wise dude and so
do the math on this and go all right
here's really what i'm spending on gas
realistically not how i feel about it
but do the math on i go this many
kilometers here's the 10 cents per liter
here's what that really amounts to in my
given week and you go okay it's about 30
bucks a week for me to get around town
in this non-electric vehicle and the
truth is you can afford it you're not
really saving that much money in the
long run you're already doing great
saving for retirement doing all these
different things and so i i don't want
you to justify the electric vehicle
purchase because of the money savings
because truthfully it takes a long time
to to get a return on investment when
buying that electric vehicle especially
if it's new
okay
you're doing great man
i love canadians they're so nice john
you're an awesome dude i'm so proud of
you you've done so well i don't want you
to move backwards by spending 50 000 on
a car when you make 60. it's just not a
wise move right now later on down the
road you're making 120 000 you're a
millionaire go ahead and buy you a 50
000 brand new electric vehicle and give
me a call back i might be 58 years old
by then hopefully i'm still doing the
show
we shall see this is the ram this is the
ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
if you've ever gone through a life
emergency you weren't prepared for
financially and that definitely includes
me
you know that's sick to your stomach
sweaty palms feeling all too well
as a parent you hope your child never
has to go through an experience like
that but teaching teenagers how to be
smart with money before they make dumb
mistakes like we did can feel like a big
job you don't have to resort to the
school of hard knocks to teach your kids
about money with our digital self-study
courses your teen will learn the right
way to handle money no matter what
curveballs life may throw at them down
the road and the best part no instructor
needed if your teen has a tablet or a
computer they're all set to start
learning how to budget save and invest
even how to write a resume and start
their own business parents get your kids
off to a great financial start and go to
ramseysolutions.com
self study to learn more about all of
the different courses we have available
for your middle or high schooler
megan joins us in fayetteville arkansas
megan welcome to the ramsay show
welcome i'm happy to be here great
having you how can i help
um i am me my husband are 25 years old
we are nearly wedged uh how do i get my
husband motivated with me to pay off our
22 000 debt that's a great question and
congrats how long has been married for
now
uh in two months it'll be a year wow
okay so we're coming up on a year and
you guys are not on the same page
financially what are the conversations
like where's his mind at and where's
yours at
well he
i am all gung-ho for it um i am
currently at a job that i'm very happy
with but i don't make very much money
and he is in transition to make a
significant
drastic change in our
uh wealth what does that mean is he
about to make a lot of money in a new
job
uh yes uh he's currently in training to
get his cdl uh we were making about 60
000 and now we're jumping up to
uh 120 000. awesome doubling the income
just like that
and so he's going well the debt's not a
big deal where's his mindset around the
ramsey plan because clearly you want to
do this plan and he doesn't
uh he he is oh we have so much money now
what can i spend it on new car new new
everything
lifestyle creeps
sweet let's increase our lifestyle now
that we have more money and we can
continue to be broke
yes
ma'am well uh you're not alone in that
problem a lot of couples
deal with this especially early on in
the marriage and the sooner we can get
you guys on the same page the better
it's going to be for your future and so
what i like to start with is the why
have you had a conversation with him
about what our hopes and dreams are for
the future instead of saying hey dave
ramsey said we need to get our debt have
you said hey what do you want our future
to look like what do you want to do when
do we want to retire
uh i we've
talked a little bit about it what we
want in life and where we see our
lifestyle game
so what what do you think is wrong with
your picture currently of of your
financial situation what are you feeling
uh
crushed i feel crushed in uh my car
payment our
house our
student loans does he know that what we
owe his parents
oh yeah
uh if i see my wife
it changes me
if she says hey honey i'm i'm feeling so
stressed i have so much anxiety about
all these payments i just really want to
get rid of these payments and move on
with their lives
have you said that to him
yeah but usually the conversation goes
with don't worry about it i i i got a
handle but it's a wee thing not a i will
handle it thing oh so he feels like he's
the savior here he's like don't worry
about it i'm about to make a lot of
money you're not going to feel a pinch
here
yeah oh boy
well the second thing we can do is is
math numbers don't lie i don't know if
he's a numbers guy
but show him on paper that the plan can
work show him what you're paying an
interest on these payments and hey we're
paying a thousand dollars in payments
every month imagine if we had that back
in our life and now we had you know 12
000 extra dollars a year to do what we
wanted and to travel and to upgrade the
car and do these house renovations
and once you do that on paper and go and
you know what i think we can do this in
like six months this is not going to
take a lot of time
and it's going to make our lives so much
better have you done that with him
uh he's actually been gone so i haven't
physically been able to do that oh he
travels a lot because of the his
industry driving around yes okay
well when he's back i want you guys to
to have a real conversation and look him
in the eyes hold his face if you need to
and go
i know you're telling me not to worry
about it i'm worried about it i want
this debt gone here's the math here's
what this looks like
have you guys gone through financial
peace university
together uh
i had the opportunity to do that
but my sister was gonna pay for it but
the check got lost in the mail and i
never had the guts to tell her it never
showed up oh
that's very sweet well how about this i
will do you a favor and i will gift it
to you i'm going to gift you a year
subscription to ramsay plus after we're
done on the phone here jenna will pick
up and get you connected to that and
here's my only ask is that you sit down
with him when he's home and you watch
all the financial peace university
videos together
and you actually pay attention put the
phones away no distractions and you have
a conversation after each video
about how you're feeling about it and
what it was what you're excited about
what you're scared about and when you do
that i want you to also do the every
dollar plus budget that comes with
ramsay plus and i want you to start
doing this on paper i'm guessing you
guys aren't doing a monthly budget
really at least he's not
uh no it's kind of we wing it
and then we'll check our bank accounts
later and you start to out outspend your
stupid
yes just out earn it well that's another
thing you guys got to start doing and
say hey here's my one requirement we've
got to do a budget every month and we're
going to track it and we're going to see
how much we actually spent
and that might change him too we might
go oh my gosh i had no idea we're
spending 850 on food for the two of us
this is insane
yeah so if you do all of those things of
one of those
if you do all of those things and it
doesn't work you might need to look into
working with a marriage counselor if
he's just totally unwilling to do any of
this because that tells me this is
beyond a financial thing this is i've
got to figure it out i have the answers
i'm going to save us and that is not
marriage that's not a team mentality
no and money fights and money problems
are the number one cause of divorce in
america today and you guys are our
bright young happy couple and i want to
keep it that way and part of that is
getting on the same page financially and
so
do the math
start with the why explain to him how
you're feeling ask him hey
george gifted me financial peace
university
my ask is that you would just sit with
me and watch these videos and if he's
unwilling to do that we've got deeper
problems
agreed
yep agreed
but we need to get rid of this debt me
and you i mean if he's not going to do
it someone's got it right
we got 22 000 in debt what kind of debt
is this
uh this is student loans car payments
loan funds to his parents
so it's heavy there's a lot
is that affecting the personal
relationship or is parents just cool
with it sitting out there do they want
this money back uh
they want it back because uh they
now are taking care of his sister's kid
so they need the money to support
another
unexpected kid and you know what that
causes on the parents side resentment
towards him and he they see him
spending like crazy having the time of
his life all the while they're owed all
this money that he said he would pay
back
which makes thanksgiving dinner really
awkward
yeah
right now you care more about this than
he does and i need you guys to have an
equal effort in this marriage and in
your finances and so jenna's gonna pick
up we'll get you connected with ramsay
plus
make sure that you dig into it together
because if you just do it on your own
we're back to where we started in fact
you're worse off because now you're even
more on fire to do this stuff and he's
just going further and further away
yep so it i mean it's going to be a hard
conversation it may take multiple
conversations but he's got to be willing
to put in effort here that is the key so
hold on jenna's going to pick up we will
get you connected with ramsay plus
and know that you're not alone couples
all over america are listening and
they're going oh my gosh i remember
doing that but i'll tell you when we
have these debt-free screams on the
stage the number one thing that people
say this is what got us on the same page
it's going through financial peace
university and here's why
it gives you shared language
shared goals shared vision around your
money when you do that your entire
marriage is going to improve not just
your money every single part of your
marriage you're going to be holding
hands on the debt-free stage and he's
going to be sitting there going yeah i
was uh avoiding it but we finally did it
and man i'm so glad we did it was so
worth it and our marriage is better than
ever that is what i want for you and
that's what i want for every young
couple in america this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm george campbell ramsey personality
and host of the fine print podcast you
are listening to the ramsay show
if you haven't checked out the fine
print it's where i talk about the hidden
truths that are keeping people broke
season one is out right now with 11
episodes and if you're not where you
want to be financially you don't know
what to do or where to turn you're
listening to headlines and social media
and your broke friends for money advice
this is the podcast for you
making the right choices doesn't have to
be complicated i jump in i do the
research for you i break down money
myths trends and traps that you need to
know about so that you can make smarter
decisions for your life and your money
you can check out the fine print on the
ramsey network or wherever you listen to
podcasts
ryan joins us in pittsburgh ryan welcome
to the ramsay show
hey how are you doing oh man this is
great i have a crew that listens to you
guys
got me pumped man it's great to hear
from you thanks for calling in how come
oh my god you guys are such a legend i
can't believe this is the first time i
ever got through wow you were the first
person to ever call me a legend so i
appreciate that
what's going on so
oh well
i i kind of have a unique situation um i
started building my own house
when i was young
and the goal was every three years to
sell them so i didn't have to pay the
capital gains
um and then eventually not have a
mortgage or anything
um but my wife's tired of moving around
since we had kids
and uh
so right now we owe
like
150 000 on our house
on your primary residence
yeah i mean it's probably worth like 300
000 because i it's all material that i
you know no labor or anything
um or contractors i did it all myself so
it's probably worth 300 000 but
the
the
other issue is
i i have a job too that i make 50 000 on
and we have a couple rental properties
that we own outright
um how many we were one
uh two two properties what are they what
are they worth
total um together together i mean we're
out in west virginia they're not worth
much i think i got them appraised that
both were like like fifty thousand fifty
five thousand
okay each of them
uh no no together yeah okay all right
and and well here's the issue i got two
issues do you think i should build
another house
and try to get all the equity because i
think i could build one out of the uh
house prices
that i could sell this for i could
probably build it without a mortgage on
the same because we have so much land i
could build another house
on the same property subdivide them or
do you think i should keep the mortgage
and i have i do have like 60 some
thousand dollars in
auto loan um
where i could i could take the rental
property and and pay those pay those off
or
or hunker down and and
so like my wife's a traveling nurse she
could get a contract and pay all that
off too so what's your household income
well that's that's the thing like i make
50 grand a year my wife makes 60 grand a
year but that doesn't like really tell
the true worth because again the salary
for the houses that we sell every three
years they we make probably another like
40 grand a year on top of that um
without reporting it as actual earned
income
interesting because of the you're
avoiding the capital gains
right by staying there for three years
uh what what are these auto loans are
there's multiple cars or one
yeah so my my wife owes 25 000 i know my
boss is really max i didn't stay with
the ramsey plan like we always have we
did it all within the last six months um
but so far nothing you've told me sounds
like you you listen to the show but you
do nothing we say
you've got a you've got a pile of debt
man you're robbing peter to pay paul
yeah well here's the deal is uh like it
all happened when i had kids i got i got
scared and nervous and and and i wanted
them to have like we were living like
like pretty pretty low and
i wanted something better for them and i
guess i wasn't prepared but i mean it is
possible that we could get out of all of
our debt and just have our mortgage with
the equity
um
if we sell our rental properties
dude you need to simplify your life i
mean i if i'm you i mean what are these
cars worth
uh the well the one car is worth 25
grand and the other car
uh i think i like 35 grand
and is it worth 35
37 37 37 grand so so i i have
like before i bought this car i had used
cars
and i would spend weekends on these 10
15 000 car like putting in transmissions
and this next
man when you're spending 10 15 grand and
you're still doing all this maintenance
you've made some
interesting decisions i do
me and the crew we do block work so it
has to carry a uh it has to it has to be
a three quarter ton vehicle
um to to carry like a
a cuba block
so i need something a little bit more
than just
i'm hearing a lot man i'm hearing a lot
of reasons why you're special and you're
unique and you need this and you need
this but you got debt in every corner
okay and you're trying to help build
your debt and say well if i just build
another house maybe we'll solve this
problem like i mean at some point it's
like a crazy person
right
so if i'm you i'm simplifying my life
i'm gonna
you clearly are a handy dude very
impressive young man how old are you
35
dude you're a rock star if you can get a
hang of this money stuff you are going
to absolutely crush it but you can't
keep going i'm going to flip the next
house in the next house because if you
were so good at this you would have all
your debt paid off if this property game
was such a lucrative business but it's
clearly not yeah so if i'm you i'm going
to lean into my career try to earn more
money if your wife's a travel nurse
they're making bank right now and so i'm
gonna hunker down sell the properties
and get rid of my car debt and if you're
not willing to sell the cars pay them
off really fast because you have sixty
thousand dollars in auto loans or more
and it's over half of your income if you
take out the property money
okay which is not guaranteed and so you
just have way too much tied up in motors
right now and i understand that you're
sick of fixing transmissions but
you can find a reliable used truck that
you're not gonna be putting constant
work into uh especially for your
business so if i'm you i'm selling the
properties
okay i'm getting rid of the car debt
first before i touch the properties we
get get rid of all the consumer debt
so if you want to speed this process up
you can sell those vehicles you don't
have to but man it's a big part of your
world right now having that much in car
payments tied up every month
that you could be using to pay down your
other debt
right i mean so if i if i
got rid of the rental properties
um
it would cover
like 99 of the the
uh
the
the
car debt but like i'd still have a
mortgage would that be okay like just
yeah that's where i want you to be
that's baby step six
or you're just focused on the mortgage
you're investing 15 of your household
income do you have kids
yeah we have two kids so you're saving
for college after you're investing 15
into retirement accounts
not into crypto whatever your crew says
is the hot investment right now 401ks
roth iras those kinds of things and then
we're going to aggressively attack the
house with everything else we have every
every ounce of margin and if you want to
you know i i just don't think you should
be going into debt to flip the house to
try to make the money back to move it
over here
and it's just there's a there's a lot of
moving parts here and i just want some
simplicity for your life where you and
your family can breathe easy and not
have to continue this chaos okay um the
last thing i was wondering uh was
so like we did
like three four years down in guatemala
um did some volunteer work down there
and
uh we we bought property down there
uh with hopes that that would be our
retirement since it's so much cheaper so
i didn't invest in a 401k because i
invested in those that property
um
you think that would be because the
healthcare is not bad so you still have
the property in guatemala
yeah i mean you don't have to pay
property tax or anything on it there
it's it's super cheap i think i paid
like
like two grand for the property and i
built a small house on it and so there's
no doubt on
man you uh you've created just a web of
of wild times
for you and your family but you're not
scared of work but you just got to get
focused man stay on the baby steps it's
a proven plan 10 million people have
done it and as special as you think you
are
this plan is gonna work for you if you
just follow it and don't try to do
ryan's plan which has caused all the
chaos that we've discovered today man
simplify simplify simplify that is
financial peace that's what i want for
you and your family this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day
deuteronomy 7 9
know therefore that the lord your god is
god
he is the faithful god keeping his
covenant of love to a thousand
generations of those who love him and
keep his commandments
brian tracy said the value of a promise
is the cost to you of keeping your word
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window covering
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from angie in
california she said
my husband and i are selling one of our
rental properties and will net hundred
and forty five thousand dollars
we also have twelve thousand dollars in
our savings account we owe three hundred
and seventy thousand on our current
mortgage and owe thirty three thousand
on a 401k loan
i want to put the whole 245 000 to the
principal of my house
that would save us over 181 thousand in
interest and we could pay off our house
in four years
should we fund our emergency fund first
or pay off the 401k loan
first even though we're just paying
ourselves back with interest
that's a great question angie appreciate
it
here's the thing
you're trying to do a lot of things at
once here
you robbed yourself
from this 401k loan you want to pay off
the house early because you're mad at
the interest but you're going into debt
and you don't have a fully funded
emergency fund and so we just have to
stay on the plan
so here's what the plan looks like if we
filter this down through the baby steps
you guys are now at baby step 2 because
of this 401k loan the good news is
you're about to net 245 000 from selling
this rental property so here's what i
would do if i was in your shoes
take the 245 000 and pay off that 401k
loan plug that money back into your 401k
so it can continue to grow and give you
guys a great retirement
now that leaves you with what 200 and
212 thousand dollars
that's some good money there and so at
that point we need to fully fund your
emergency fund because you're then out
of baby step two into three so that if
let's say you know that's thirty
thousand dollars for you guys so we're
gonna add an additional eighteen
thousand to fully fund the emergency
fund and the rest of that you can apply
towards the mortgage
so no i would not apply 245 to the
mortgage and still leave leave
yourselves without an emergency fund and
left with this 401k loan clean that up
first you can put almost 200 grand on
the mortgage which will bring it down to
170 and then you're in baby step six and
you're gonna attack this with a
vengeance with all the margin you have
while investing 15 of your income into
retirement if you've got kids we've got
to be investing something for college as
well so that's the plan don't try to
short it it just doesn't work the
shortcuts will lead you to pain and
misery and anxiety and confusion and all
kinds of things
follow the plan it works every time
good stuff there lori joins us in los
angeles california lori welcome to the
ramsay show
hi george thanks so much for taking my
call i really appreciate it absolutely
how can i help today
great you're the perfect person because
my question is regarding thank you i
have a son that's going to be
you are you really are
uh some that's going to be going to
college this august right so um out of
state so we're concerned about like how
we can help him if in case there's any
emergencies we don't want to financial
emergency so we don't want to open up a
credit card program which is what we did
for our older son just for like because
books are crazy expensive right or if he
has a medical emergency or it's just
something else that comes up but we
don't know how to help him because we're
not we can't just you know give him
money like quickly like that so without
opening up a credit card what would you
recommend that we do to help him
stay out of trouble or you know
sure in my hand if he needs that well
the first thing i think
take a step back first of all awesome
job that you are not going to open a
credit card for him like you did with
your other son that is the move the
credit card is the gateway drug into all
kinds of other debt as he gets older so
i want him to stay away from debt is he
able to cash flow the college experience
yeah so we have been saving and we have
about two years of it's we estimate
about twenty thousand dollars a year so
um for college and we've got about two
years um saved for him so we should be
good there okay that's good news so as
far as him having emergencies in college
i mean his life is pretty cushy is he
living on campus out of state
he's going to be living on campus yes
okay and is he on your health insurance
still
yes okay so as far as financial
emergencies i mean we've got health
insurance so there's a fear that's taken
away there we're going to be able to to
pay for any out of pocket medical costs
god forbid something happened
right
yes and then the other emergencies like
books are not emergencies at all right
we know that we need books every
semester
and so that's going to be part of the
budget that we use to cash flow the
college experience and go all right
books are going to be 600 this year
they're going to be 750 and guess what
don't buy them from the campus bookstore
go buy them used off some used book
websites go find the digital version
there's so many options out there and
half the time you don't even need the
book so make sure once you get in that
class talk to the professor and go hey
listen i don't really have the money to
be paying for all these books do we
really need it is this something where i
can print it out can i work with another
student what are my options here and see
what they say
so he needs to get creative and i want
him to fight for himself it's really
sweet that you're calling in on his
behalf but i want him to feel the
pressure of i'm a big boy now i don't
live with mom and dad anymore i've got
to figure this out
versus you guys you know bailing him out
so have you guys had the conversation
with him
yeah yeah yes we have but after this
call definitely i mean we watch borrowed
future and just like
kind of put the fear of god into him
kind of sort of but yeah that kind of so
thank you for that and i and i know
we're budgeting we're doing the everyday
dollar app and all that stuff stupid so
for sure i think you can just put it in
my head to in his account his his bank
account he just needs to have that money
available for the books that was my
biggest fear but yeah he needs to have
his own emergency fund i want him to
have to figure out oh gosh okay i need
to i need to be able to budget for this
every semester because truthfully that's
the stuff i wish i learned when i went
to college and instead what we do to our
kids is we we baby them we hand hold
them and then they turn 21 22 and they
leave college and they go oh my gosh i
have no idea how to do anything
how the heck do you pay for things how
do i budget how do i file taxes
i know and so that leads to my second
hopefully quick question is that so we
don't we have the money rights we don't
want to take out a loan but we kind of
we want to know that he has skin in the
game like we did with our older son
unfortunately this was before dave
before we knew about dave so we paid for
80 of his his tuition and he paid for 20
with a loan we paid off our portion
already but he's still paying for it so
now i feel bad that we're helping him
pay for it because what's left because
he's having a hard time i don't want to
make the same mistake with this one but
i want so when i told my older son that
you need we want you to take that loan
so you have some skin in the game he
said i get it mom that'll help me
graduate faster he graduated in three
and a half years so it worked so but i
don't want to do that to this one
because we have the money but we want
him to have something in the game too
what do you recommend you know if can he
work part-time while he's in school
because we found that actually increases
your gpa and creates more discipline
so i i think you make it a you make a
requirement say hey you know this much
of what you make or you're gonna have to
cover this much extra by working over
the summer or part time while you're in
school so that you've got skin in the
game because i do think that's important
if mom and dad are just cash flowing his
life he's not going to feel the need to
even graduate in four years he's going
to become a sixth year graduate because
he's having such a great time on your
dime
yep exactly okay nothing wrong with with
putting him to work and going hey you're
going to you're going gonna cash flow
five thousand dollars make it reasonable
you know he's not gonna make 40 grand
while he's in college but make it
something reasonable and tell him debt
is not an option it's off the table and
you're gonna have to get creative you
need to apply for scholarships and
grants and and fafsa and do do whatever
it takes it doesn't have to be his own
money he earned from work but he's got
to cash flow this thing and get creative
okay and that's really going to make him
a better adult don't you think
absolutely and that's what we're trying
to do so he's number two and we don't
want to make a mistake that we did with
the first guy because we're helping him
get out of it so because we feel bad
after we learned what what dave's um you
know
uh rules of
engagement were so now we know better
yeah
well there's nothing wrong with uh with
the kids learning that lesson and i'm
glad you learned the lesson of saying
hey we don't want it to be this way i
mean you're changing your family tree by
saying never again are we going to have
a kid that graduates with all this debt
and he's going mom dad i thought you
were helping me
not putting me into debt putting me in
chains when i graduate and get a job so
you guys are doing amazing i'm proud of
you thank you for watching the bar
future documentary and and making those
changes and wanting to see your kid grow
up into a successful adult that's the
goal
yeah
thanks so much for the call lori
appreciate it
that puts this hour of the ramsay show
in the books our thanks to ben running
the board today jenna on the phones
kelly our associate producer zach and
nathan run on the youtube side and the
video stuff and you america appreciate
you listening on this day where i'm
flying solo appreciate the support thank
you guys so much spend wisely save
intentionally give generously this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsey network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
send clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you